okay so the cue catchy this one's quite
short but it's quite quite interesting
exercise every it's also called the soul
in those sounds she's supposed to do
high levels not touch the swords and it
kind of comes into its own when you're
either doing it that way or you using
your hardness deflection to throw the
soil into the next attack now it's kind
of an advanced I see these the more
basic series of videos so we're gonna
sort of slow it down so it looks more
like a simpler thing of two cuts but
just bear in mind it sort of that's
moving to a slightly more advanced phase
looks good look at the variations as
well
okay now lady this one starts with me
attempting to attack son I'm not piece
off one side and try and come in there
so that's that's the basic basis of the
first move now that is sometimes so you
get it not way people immediately start
going to the defense I've I've always
tried to get the attackee that I'll have
a feeling getting the attacking my
attention is always to not sortsite and
to attack and I have to change my mind
get out yeah as I mentioned in the
earlier videos I think it's quite
important to get this sort of interplay
between the two two people if you just
go straight back people becomes less of
this one exercise so I'm not waiting to
feely of attacking he immediately comes
around it's the first cut it comes
around
[Music]
hey little bit faster Priscilla but
pause between each move so this is
that's quite simple when it gets to the
higher levels gives a little bit more
[Music]
first variation
I'm knock away he comes around control
the arm head these kind of cuts using a
hand on top can be really powerful cuts
the slice deeply it's a pleasure enjoy
this is some more less controlling
there's also an option to Hey
first bloody variation I pick up here
holds the old style was to step with
these foot take you down there okay
that's kind of dangerous I've just shown
that but that boys you through that
broken ankles so you're more more than
practice that tend to get a meaty pretty
good idea not to do that but second salt
variation thanks for your piece of the
first one on the opposite side so it's
like wait here probably the reason on
this side second body variation
is the same as effectively as the
variation second body variation on
second cue catchy so I shall refer you
to that video to look at that okay
okay so that's the cube Itachi kind of
shoulder sweet there's a little bit more
to it than meets the eye
hope you learn from that okay thanks
[Music]